steigende Mieten explodierende
Nebenkosten müssen sich unsere
Abgeordneten hingegen keine Sorgen
machen schon jetzt haben die 736
Abgeordneten ja eigentlich ein nettes
Einkommen ab Juli wird es dann noch mal
ein bisschen mehr die Diäten steigen um
3,4 Prozent so stark wie übrigens seit
2015 nicht mehr konkret heißt das pro
Kopf 350 € mehr Macht im Summe dann
10.674 € Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel
Bass bekommt um die 700 € mehr Herr
Herne verstehen sie die Wut einiger
Bürger wenn man diese Zahlen hört die
verstehe ich voll und ganz
vor allem auch wenn es dann zusätzlich
noch um Europa geht die greifen ja noch
viel tiefer in die Kasse aber ich habe
bei der Bild am Sonntag mal vor zehn
Jahren eine Kolumne geschrieben als es
auch um das Thema ging und da habe ich
genau die Gegenposition vertreten und
gesagt
anständige Diäten für die Politiker dann
werden sie nicht korrupt dann brauchen
Sie keine Nebentätigkeiten und und und
man kann sie gar nicht gut genug
bezahlen und man kann die Geschichte
auch ganz einfach lösen wir halbieren
den Bundestag dann haben wir die Hälfte
der Kosten ich bin ohnehin der
Auffassung Politiker müssen gerade
stehen für das was sie machen und was
sie beschließen also jeder Politiker
müsste seine Kinder in Brennpunkt
Schulen schicken was meinen wir wie
schnell wir das
migrations-thema erledigt hätten
Politiker müssen jetzt ein Windrad
direkt vor ihre Wohnung gestellt kriegen
was meinen Sie wie schnell wir dieses
Problem gelöst hätten es ist eigentlich
ganz einfach und es dürfen nur noch in
den Bundestag Leute die einen
abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung haben
und dann haben wir so wenig
brauchen Sie gar kein Geld haben viele
Vorschläge oder jetzt gerade zusammen
was man machen könnte man macht hier ein
bisschen das gegen leider Bundestag so
groß wie nie und jetzt gibt es noch mal
Geld oben drauf aber Herr Hahne sagt
auch gute Leute brauchen vielleicht dann
auch gutes Geld also können sie ihnen
die Erhöhung nein nein weil ich glaube
nicht dass mit mehr Arbeitsaufwand
verbunden ist es ist auch nicht mehr
eine besseren Qualität der Arbeit
verbunden es ist Status und es ist ein
Selbstbedienungsladen und im Übrigen
muss ich in einem Punkt widersprechen
Leute die gut bezahlt werden neigen auch
zu Korruption man kann nicht sagen dass
die Leute den Europaparlament Arbeiten
an der Hungergrenze dahinvegetieren nein
Geld macht verführerisch und ähm nicht
Geld machen kein Geld macht auch korrupt
also es ist jedenfalls immer ein Zug von
Korruption da und außerdem wissen Sie
wenn Sie die Hälfte der Abgeordneten
weglassen werden sie nicht die Hälfte
der Ausgaben sparen es gibt zum Beispiel
sowas wie fixe Kosten der Bundeswehr
muss unterhalten werden die bleiben und
wie weit sind Spanien ist eine Frage der
Berechnung ich glaube nicht dass sie
Ersparnis groß werden trotzdem gehört
der Bundestag verkleidet und man könnte
vielleicht mal damit anfangen dass man
den Neubau des Bundeskanzlers Amtes sind
Umwelt und daraus ein flüchtlingspartier
machen dann wäre es endlich eine
vernünftige Zweckbestimmung wir sind
gute Leute sollen auch gutes Geld
verdienen wie stehen Sie zu diesem Thema
finden Sie diese Diäten Erhöhung
berechtigt
ich finde sie berechtigt weil die
hygienten steigen ja nicht schneller als
die Gehälter im privaten Sektor sondern
genauso und wenn die um vier Prozent
hochgehen und wir haben acht Prozent
Inflation dann heißt das real gehen sie
um 4% runter also worüber regt man sich
hier auf die Bürger keine
Inflationsausgleich sind auch die
Abgeordneten haben keinen Folgen
Inflationsausgleich überall
ja nur gut von der anderen Seite aber es
ist ja die Frage nach dem Zuwachs und
der Zuwachs
stabilisiert den Status Quo nicht
sondern ist nicht genug um das zu
kompensieren ich meine man kann der
Meinung sein die verdienen überhaupt zu
viel ist ein ganz anderes Thema als die
Frage nach dieser Anpassung ehrlich die
Anpassung ist indexiert mit der normalen
Gehaltsentwicklung das ist quasi die
wirtschaftliche Sicht 25% der deutschen
machen sich natürlich aber auch Sorge
dass sie ihre Miete derzeit nicht mehr
zahlen können und für die ist natürlich
so eine Erhöhung verständlich
ja nun Sorgen macht man sich immer die
Mieten sind immer so hoch dass man sie
sich kaum leisten kann weil im
Wettbewerb untereinander man das Hoch
konkurriert aber
Mieter sind im Moment
tendenziell
nicht auf der Verliererseite dieser
Inflation sind den meisten sind die
Mieten nicht indexiert sondern einfach
nominal
definiert und die Gewerkschaften sorgen
dafür zu Recht dass die Löhne steigen
mit der Inflation und die Mieten steigen
nicht mit das heißt relativ neben die
Mieten dann auch ab also zu sagen dass
die Mieter jetzt in der heutigen Zeit
die besonders gelangweilten sein dieser
Inflation das ist auch inhaltlich falsch
aber als wäre reingrätschen die ähm
Leute empfinden das natürlich als
ungerecht weil sie ja im Endeffekt
erleben Sie ja dass derselbe Politiker
der sagt wir müssen den Gürtel enger
schneiden
so diese ganzen Nummern die gönnen sich
dann
diese Erhöhungen also ich möchte da
nicht ins Private gehen aber ich habe
das ganz klar als erster damals hat sich
noch keine getraut bei der Lindner
Hochzeit gesagt man kann sich nicht
morgens vor die Weltöffentlichkeit
stellen und zu sagen und das war konkret
so wir müssen jetzt den Gürtel enger
schneiden wir müssen sparen sparen
sparen und dann setzt man sich ins
Flugzeug mit
der ganzen Infrastruktur die ja Minister
haben
Flugzeuge und und Begleitfahrzeug ich
habe das alles erlebt ich war ja Sie
können den Leuten nicht doch ich gönne
ihnen was aber es muss glaubwürdig sein
es muss glaubwürdig sein und das ist ein
Vertrauensverlust den wir gegenwärtig
haben die wir haben ja keine Politik
Verdrossenheit wir haben eine Politik
Verdrossenheit das haben wir schon
länger
nein aber das gab es ja immer schon
diesen Selbstbedienungsladen ja aber
eskaliert gerade fragen wir doch mal
einen Nutznießer quasi dieser Erhöhung
die sind sehr mit uns am Tisch für Sie
gibt's ja ein bisschen mehr ich glaube
380 € oder ich bin ganz dankbar dass sie
das ausgerechnet haben weil ich weiß das
gar nicht weil das ist ja eine Kopplung
eine Kopplung an die Löhne im übrigen
auch in dem Fall wenn die Löhne sinken
dann sinken ja auch die Diäten was im
letzten Jahr der Fall war und deswegen
schadet vielleicht auch so ein bisschen
sachliche Argumentation in diesem Fall
nicht der sogenannte
Selbstbedienungsladen den haben wir uns
nicht ausgedacht ich wäre froh wenn ich
eine Kommission einsetzen könnte die
sagt entscheidet ihr darüber wann
Abgeordnete irgendwie mehr Geld bekommen
oder nicht und ob das angemessen ist er
hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht aber
gesagt das geht nicht das haben die
Abgeordneten gefährlich selbst zu
entscheiden und ich glaube die
Möglichkeit irgendwie Diäten zu erhöhen
dafür wird es nie einen richtigen
Zeitpunkt geben
ich verdiene jetzt mit diesen Diäten
genauso viel wie mein Landrat der
genauso wie ich für einen für diese für
diesen Bereich eines Landkreises mit
240.000 Menschen zuständig ist
auch da kann man fragen ist der Landrat
überbezahlt oder nicht ist kapriziert
sich dann häufig nur auf die
Bundestagsabgeordnete aber da ist es
eben genauso wie was ist angemessen und
da haben wir damals als Bundestag gesagt
wir setzen eine Kommission ein aus
Gewerkschaft an aus
arbeitgebervertretern aus
Arbeitnehmervertretern Handwerkern aus
aus allen Bereichen der Gesellschaft und
die haben dann erarbeitet dass es
möglicherweise sinnvoll ist die die
Diäten Erhöhungen an die Lohnentwicklung
in Deutschland zu koppeln das heißt wenn
die Gesamtsituation so ist dass die
Menschen in Deutschland mehr Geld
bekommen dann bekommen Politiker auch
mehr Geld oder diejenigen die dann für
die Politik in Deutschland bundesweit
zuständig sind und wenn das umgekehrt
der Fall ist wird Ihnen die Diät auch
gekürzt ich finde das ist angesichts der
Tatsache dass man sowieso nie eine
zufriedenstellende Lösung erreichen wird
noch unter den schlechtesten die beste
ist ja auch das war auch eben gerade
Thema hier das ist nicht Gelenk daran
haben sie auch jahrelang gearbeitet im
Bundestag zu verschlanken woran
scheitert es denn da nun zunächst mal
ist das keine Entscheidung des
Bundestages gewesen sondern eine
Entscheidung ist des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes da gab es
eine Situation in Dresden bei einer
Nachwahl entstand das sogenannte
negative Stimmgewicht das heißt jemand
dürfte nicht zu viele Stimmen haben um
dann den Bundestag zu kommen absurde
Situation da hätte man natürlich sagen
können okay das ist eine Ausnahme bei
einem sonst Funktion gut funktionieren
im Wahlrecht das lassen wir jetzt mal
als Ausnahme so stehen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat das zum
Anlass genommen neu über die über das
Wahlrecht eine Entscheidung zu treffen
und da wurde dann entschieden wenn es
sogenannte Überhangmandate gibt
bisschen kompliziert also wenn man mehr
Wahlkreise gewinnt als der Partei nach
den Zweitstimmen zusteht dann kommt es
zu Überhangmandaten und da hat das für
die anderen für die anderen nee also
erstmal für die Partei und die werden
dann ausgeglichen durch sogenannte
Ausgleichsmandate für die anderen
Parteien und dann erhöhte sich die
eigentlich zuvor das vergisst man auch
schnell vom Bundestag beschlossene
Reduzierung der Abgeordneter 598 und
jetzt haben wir über 700 und ist besteht
überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel daran dass
das zu groß ist und dass man das
reduzieren will und wie man das macht
über den Weg da wird jetzt trefflich
gestritten
Selbstbedienungsladen so energisch
zurückweisen es gibt zum Beispiel eine
Art von Parteien Finanzierung hier ist
bei anderen durchaus demokratischen
Ländern mit gleich längere demokratische
Geschichte nicht geben ich habe die
Zahlen nicht im Kopf viele Millionen die
an die Partei Stiftungen die Parteien
ausgeschüttet werden und das sind
abschiebestationen das wissen sie besser
als ich dass Leute die irgendwie als
Politiker gescheitert sind wie er man
Martin Schulz zum Beispiel die finden
immer noch ein warmes Plätzchen in ihrer
Partei Stiftung nicht war in der
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung oder wie sie
gerade heißt schlimm dass da expolitiker
arbeiten oder finden Sie schlimm dass es
überhaupt Stiftung gibt die an der
Willensbildung sozusagen des Volkes ja
nur wirklich sinnvoll Mitarbeiter das
würde ich erstmal in Frage stellen diese
Stiftungen sind versorgungsorgane tun
sie jetzt nicht so als wäre das ihnen
erst jetzt in dem Moment klar geworden
wo ich gesagt habe sie wissen es viel
besser die sind alle besetzt alle durch
andere
mit Leuten die eine Kompensation
brauchen genauso das EU-Parlament eine
Weile soll das Abkühlbecken für Versager
gewordenen Opa schicken nach Europa wir
können zusammen singen
die Stiftung der Parteien haben eine
wichtige Rolle bei der Entwicklungshilfe
die sind ja in allen Ländern vertreten
und bringen sich dort in die politische
Willensbildung ein
kooperieren dann auch im übrigen sehr
gut und mit den Botschaften das also
Teil der Auslandsvertretung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland was das
Personal betrifft ja das haben wir eine
überall dass da Leute irgendwo
abgeschlossen werden
nur gut wenn wir noch viele hätten die
so gut sind und da bin ich bei Ihnen
Herr Bruder wenn sie sagen also mich
stört es die Leute im großen Teils im
Bundestag gar keine abgeschlossene
Ausbildung haben gesagt ich bin selber
ich würde das nein nein ich habe gesagt
geschlossene berufskraft wäre nein das
ist kein Studium
nein nur ein Schritt weiter
abgeschlossen
ja und wenn man fachkundige
Entscheidungen treffen will für das Volk
da muss man ja auch wissen worüber man
entscheidet ja man muss man kann sich
dann sortieren im Bundestag in die
entsprechenden Gremien sie sind in der
Wirtschaft andere sind im sozialen und
so weiter und mindestens da muss ich
also eine berufliche Kompetenz
mitbringen wenn ich da entscheiden will
das geht es ja um viel und meistens hört
man und es wird nur irgendwas
vorbereitet und dann sitzt man da im
Parlament und nicht das ab ohne dass man
weiß worüber man überhaupt beschlossen
hat da sind ja Umfragen gewesen bei
Abgeordneten die aus dem Plenarsaal raus
kam worüber haben Sie den jetzt
beschlossen können Sie was erklären
haben wie Journalisten gefragt
werden
beispielsweise 20 Millionen jetzt
ausgegeben um Rechtsexperten dran zu
holen ist das denn der richtig dass man
sagt
natürlich auch viele Rechtsexperten im
Ministerium
wozu braucht er dann extreme Kräfte das
ist schon dann viel Geld ne also es gibt
ja auch den wissenschaftlichen Beirat
Bayern Habeck den kann er Fragen der
kostet gar nichts der arbeitet
ehrenamtlich da bin ich übrigens auch
dabei da gehe ich morgen hin ja aber da
haben wir doch eine
Selbstbedienungsladen das heißt es
werden jetzt in dieser Regierung
scheint mir so ein paar Vorurteile zu
haben
Gleichstellungsbeauftragten jetzt müssen
sie doch strahlen wenn ich jetzt sage
dass die ganze Zeit ja ich merke ich
dass die ähm in diesem einen Jahr sind
von ingo's und wer weiß was alles Leute
plötzlich ministerial beamtenberater
oder
ja das ist der Selbstbedienungsladen den
ich finde das ganz schön
Selbstbedienungsladen gehen
Selbstbedienungsladen klingt immer so
als müsste man da irgendwo in die Kasse
greifen ich gebe sofort
dass die Leute häufig gar nicht die
Ausbildung haben für das was uns oder
sie natürlich ein echtes Problem die
Lobbyisten jetzt in den Ministerien an
also sowas hat es noch nie gesehen also
bitte sind die Vertreter der Partei
Stiftungen sind nicht Teil des
Auswärtigen Dienstes und diese Arbeit
aber mit denen zusammen
natürlich arbeiten sie zusammen sind
sehr witzige Situationen die dabei
stehen ich habe mal alle diese
Stiftungen in Washington besucht weil
ich weiß darüber machen wollte und schon
sehen Sie dann war ich so an wie wieder
dass ich das Projekt habe fallen lassen
dieser Stiftungen für ein absolutes
eigentlich leben und die z.B in Amerika
die werden dazu da die sind nein es geht
nicht nur um die überfordern
Geldversorgung unserer Amerika sind an
demokratieprojekten beteiligt ich fand
das sehr witzig dass die Leute nach
Amerika schicken um den Amis Demokratie
beizubringen das ist wahrscheinlich
Entschuldigung in Afghan vielleicht
haben wir nicht nur die beigebracht
haben wir nicht nur in den USA Stiftung
sondern es gab auch eine Stiftung die
Moskau es gibt eine Stiftung in vielen
Staaten wo die Leute wo die Menschen vor
Ort früh froh sind das ist Stiftung gibt
und ich rede jetzt nicht nur von der
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung sondern von mir
aus auch von anderen Stiftungen für die
Ebert Stiftung damit muss ansprechen
besonders gut geklappt die sind dann im
Zweifel diskriminiert worden oder
rausgeschmissen worden das ist natürlich
das Problem die werden ja auch nicht
entschuldigen
neue deutsche Imperialismus wird gut
fragen
weil dann höre ich mir das gerne an was
sie erzählen von
selbstbedienungsanleitung ja das mache
ich auch schon die ganze Zeit wie Sie
sehen wenn ich anfange zu erklären werde
ich ja unterbrochen aber das ist jetzt
meine Chance mal kurz darauf hinzuweisen
dass wir jetzt immer springen von dem
einen zum anderen diese Stiftung ich sag
das mal übergreifen kann man kritisieren
aber man sollte zumindest akzeptieren
dass die in weiten Teilen der Welt
wirklich sinnvolle Arbeit machen um
Menschenrechte zu schützen und
demokratische Strukturen zu fördern ob
das immer gelingt ist eine ganz andere
Frage und völlig unabhängig davon welche
was ist Anmaßung dass man da dass man da
vor Ort arbeitet und die Leute reden auf
jeden Fall haben
aber wissen Sie nur
ein kleines ablassen in Afghanistan hat
eine Stiftung ein äh Ausbildung
angeboten wie man getrennt Müll sammelt
ja das finde ich ganz wichtig
entscheidend für die Demokratisierung
Afghanistan ich sage mal voraussetzbar
wahrscheinlich nicht die konrad-stift
nein der gute Kontrolle
sagt ja ich wollte nur mit Herrn Hahne
bin ich der Auffassung dass das in
manchen Ministerien auch mit
verhandelndem Ressourcen gearbeitet
werden könnte ohne dass man immer was
dazu kaufen muss das finde ich auch das
nenne ich aber nicht
Selbstbedienungsladen sondern das nenne
ich vielleicht falsche Struktur oder von
mir aus auch eine falsche personellen
aufwuchs der nicht nötig ist gerade in
Zeiten wo man vielleicht mit dem Geld
ein bisschen sparsamer umgehen kann wenn
wir sowieso 500 Milliarden Euro
mittlerweile aufnehmen also der aktuelle
Finanzminister hat so viel Schulden
gemacht in einem Jahr wie in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland von 1949 bis
1990 ob man dann noch bei dieser
Situation zusätzlich in den Ministerien
sich 100 zusätzliche Stellenplan das ist
eine Berechtigung